you got a crooked nose when your ears is
[__] up your top look is stupid your
hairline is [__] up and one of my ears
is done
and your skin complexion makes my balls
itch
which of your co-stars would you like to
switch with I'm gonna I'm gonna play DJ
too
because I don't know what it's like to
be stupid
um
who you want to fight at this point in
time I'll probably go to rock one thing
about The Rock he a big boy he can
wrestle yeah but the muscles kind of
slow you down but God damn right there
he's a hell of an actor yo he's an actor
but I better I'll break his face you
know we had a little incident on the set
of Jumanji nobody knows about it we got
to a little shoving match man this is
some bullets this ain't a lie you can
ask anybody that was on set that day we
got into an argument and I was like yo
you're not hitting your mark he was like
Kevin Yellowman from all his people and
I was like and these people he's like
who are you talking to I said I'm
talking to you and that's when he pushed
me I said do it again what I did I had
salt I had salt in my like in my uh in
my pants like at the top he didn't know
it so when he came up I said and I put
the salt in his eye yeah and he was like
ah
everybody knows that I carry salt in the
left side of my pants in case of
emergency and we had a hallway bump in
uh I forgot the awards show okay I'm an
award he was backstage we saw each other
just before we met I do remember that
and he was like Hey Rock and I was like
um
oh my God I kept my heart I'm such a big
fan yeah my security that's right I
remember yes what's going on here um
what do you say it like that for wait a
minute
yeah what's what's going on there is
dude
first of all when I look at this picture
the first thing I say is thank God he's
bald
who won't pick up the check you're going
out you guys Dwayne Dwayne Dwayne
you also just recently bought your mom a
house
[Laughter]
all right all right should we clap for
that I think the whole room right now is
taking the same thing it's about
their middle name easy uh come on
Croatia no Croatia yes no man the Wayne
Croatia Johnson no not at all that's not
even close I thought you didn't your
mother have a story about Croatian she
said that she would love to go to
Croatia but it wasn't like that's my
middle name get out of here okay Douglas
man Dwayne douglas douglas yeah that's
[__] stupid wow really we've talked
about this wow okay Jesus Christ what's
your middle name Darnell Darnell yes
well that [__] sucks
two D's in a row Kevin Darnell Hart
double dick Kevin Darnell Wayne doesn't
gonna [__] pay to see that name yeah
don't laugh like that don't whoa that's
okay well there's my picture
what does that just leave it
what don't laugh like that you look like
a detective that's a DJ
Dwayne Johnson don't say it breath
smells like [__] on the regular and
nobody knows this you wanna know where
the eyebrow raise came from it came from
the reaction to people hello and
everybody knows
that's what The Rock is cooking shitty
bread okay don't encourage him they're
pet peeve got it no this one
what is it smelling his balls right here
that's my pet peeve yeah you do it all
the time we're on set and I'll catch you
in a corner no but it's not a pet people
I enjoy doing that
[Laughter]
I know when the streaming doesn't go
well when you're watching uh PornHub
yeah well that's your pet oh that's good
yeah I wasn't born in Hawaii you lived
there in San Francisco but I did a lot
of my growing up there so yeah so it was
it was amazing I don't know I don't
think no tell me
before you saying for years I've always
said when we were there you gave me a
big speech like this is my land I
started
why are you dressed like that because
it's my costume all you gotta do is go
to the costume store and say make me
look stupid don't stand like that that's
not how I said I didn't stand like that
over
[Laughter]
this is a cliff where I was born
this is the problem
you'll try to be respectful you want
some candy oh you want the king-sized
candy yeah no you don't get that at all
here's what you get it's bite size tiny
mini like you I don't want that put this
in your fanny pack maybe next year you
don't try to save money on your
decorations around here hey kids Dwayne
The Rock Johnson is giving out raisins
and pennies this sucks okay okay stupid
house okay I would like to know what you
would do if you could spend 24 hours in
in Kevin Hart's body how would you spend
your day kill myself that's what I do
wait a second no no no I wouldn't do it
it's a great day it is a great day you
had an opportunity for a terrific day 24
hours in The Rock's body well all right
15 he'd be playing himself
[Laughter]
and I'm gonna go redo some of the movies
I want to do Scorpion Kick you want to
redo it I'm A reduced scorpion okay no I
just wanna I just want to be a part of
that I've yet to have that and I'm gonna
go to like fast I'm gonna go to fast 26.
fast and furious 26. Jumanji now yeah
with uh my man uh Dwayne Johnson
yes yes we love him we love you you're
just good good good people in there I'm
I'm so much better than him let's not
say that not not like in a way where
we're competing but if we were I would
be better
it's going to be [__] amazing Dwayne
get on my [__] comment section
go do something man
you know what I got something for your
ass I got something for your ass do it
again
do it again and I'm gonna click on you
and I click on you let the people see
how you look during the daytime news
flash Dwayne's forehead isn't real
it's
Dwayne The Rock Johnson has a prosthetic
forehead
it's not real it makes it worse though
Big Time snore still coming out now okay
well you fart in your sleep how about
that that's a different situation he
farts in his sleep it's a not my best
friend whatever he sleeps with a diaper
all right these are personal problems
that nobody needs to know this one goes
to all of the co-stars that I've had
except the rock because he hasn't helped
me
help me at all you've actually lessened
my talent it's a twin down since you've
been in my life you guys have any party
chicks or anything oh we have many I
can't come over well first can you wait
a second
time TJ can ties balls
okay older guys so
much
balls and without using my hands I just
kind of
I shake my hips
[Laughter]
beautiful very good
thank you thank you so much that
sustained smoldering it's very
impressive yes
all right look sometimes well oftentimes
things get intense here in the iron
Paradise but we ain't playing Tiddly
wings and we ain't reciting nursery
rhymes all right you get lumped up every
once in a while and things happen
[Music]
that's good that's real good back to
work what up world
I just got done doing session number two
in the gym
sometimes when you clinging and banging
[__] happens
way get to getting thrown
and sometimes you wake up with a little
knot
hey Dwayne
you ain't the only one getting hit in
the head with 45 pound dumbbells
and 45 pound plates
because I am too
hard work
granted I'm a little dizzy
might have a concussion
but that ain't got a [__] thing
to do with my motive
I'm gonna be honest I ain't feeling too
good